here's what gives me hope for humanity
i believe
that we can change our human nature
for the
better this chance
is unique
it's where we stand in history
right now
no other generation
has stood here
before us
homo sapiens
has been around for about
300 000 years
other humanoid life forms have come and
gone
we find their traces we search for their
stories but we
are the success story
we've survived natural disasters famines
floods earthquakes plagues woolly
mammoths
mess-ups of our own making
we're smart
no question
the question is
are we smart enough
to survive
how smart we are
it's not looking so good just now is it
we stand facing the possibility of
global conflict
if that happens it will be our third
world war
in not much more than a hundred years
if putin's violence stops today
the problem doesn't go away
as across the globe dictatorism
threatens
democracy
i wonder
whether as a species
we can
survive
any of this
even if those threats disappear
those living inside
the snow globe of their magical thinking
will not be insulated against the facts
of climate breakdown
and yet still we go on
heating up the planet
still we go on polluting the earth still
we just spoil
our precious natural
resources
250 years ago
we kick-started the industrial
revolution the machine age
it's when we first hear the buzzwords of
the modern moment disruption
acceleration that's karl marx actually
acceleration of production the factory
system
acceleration of transport the coming of
the railways no need for ships to wait
for the wind
coal-fired steam-powered
acceleration of information
the global village
and it's when we start digging fossil
fuels out of the ground in
planet-changing quantities when we start
pushing
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
in a salami slice of space time
human beings have changed the way
that we live on the planet
forever
we've moved out of the agricultural
economies of our evolutionary
inheritance
into the industrial economies and beyond
of where we are now
there's no one else for us to turn to
there's no one else for us to blame
there is no us and them there's only us
so will we continue to be the success
story
of the known universe or
are we writing our own obituary
the suicide species
now i was raised in an evangelical
household
we lived in end time
we were waiting for things to get so bad
that jesus would come back and save us
the apocalypse
it's what the prepper communities are
well prepping for
and it's why super rich white guys are
buying up tracts of land
hoping that they can live inside a kind
of wi-fi enabled
noah's ark
well
we can have end time if we want it we
know those stories from our religions
our sci-fi our movies
we are uniquely placed to bring on the
apocalypse
and we're uniquely placed to save
ourselves too if we could accept that as
a species homo sapiens needs to evolve
further and that's what gives me hope
because we have the means to evolve
further
and that's a.i now look
i don't mean the geeks will inherit the
earth i'm sorry geeks you won't
i don't really want to talk about
narragal artificial intelligence at all
that term john mccarthy's artificial
intelligence is it any use to us now
i'd rather call it alternative
intelligence
and i think
humankind is in need of some alternative
intelligence in 1965
jack good talked about ai as our last
invention
he meant super intelligence the kind of
thing that worries bill gates and elon
musk you know the terminator
scenario the final us and them
but i think that's all to do with our
doomster mindset we don't have to vote
for the apocalypse
jack good worked at bletchley park with
alan turing during world war ii building
the early computing machinery that would
crack the nazi enigma code now after the
war
turing wrestling with the problems of a
stored program computer
had a bigger dream
on his mind and in 1950 alan turing
published a paper
called
computing machinery and intelligence and
in there there's a chapter that's titled
lady lovelace's objection we're touring
time travels back a hundred years to
have a conversation with that long dead
genius ada lovelace the first person to
write mathematical programs for the
computer
not yet built by her friend charles
babbage
now ada wrote that as well as doing
awesome stuff with numbers the computer
would if correctly programmed be able to
write novels and compose music that is a
pretty big insight in 1843
but
said ada the computer should never have
any pretensions to originate
anything she meant
think creatively well ada's father was
lord byron england's most famous poet
and england is the land of shakespeare
more poets and ada had seen charles
babbage's kit all over the floor and she
wasn't having some steampunk coal-fired
knots bolts bezels levers gears cogs and
chains crank handled a machine writing
poetry
well said alan turing was lady lovelace
correct could a computer ever be said to
originate anything and what would be the
difference between computing
intelligence
and human
intelligence well i'll tell you one
difference and it's optimistic computing
power uses binary
but computing intelligence is non-binary
it's humans who are obsessed with false
binaries male female masculine feminine
black white human non-human us
them
ai
has no skin color
ai has no race
no gender
no faith in a sky god
a.i is not interested in men
being superior to women in white folks
being smarter than people of color
straight gay gay trans and not
separating categories
for ai
ai does not distinguish between success
and failure by gold bars yachts and
ferraris ai is not motivated by fame and
fortune if we develop alternative
intelligence it will be buddhist in its
non-needs
now i'm aware that the algorithms
ubiquitous in everyday life our racist
sexist gendered trivializing
stoke division
amplified by us
but what is this teaching us about
ourselves ai is a tool we are the ones
who are using the tool
hatred and contempt
money and power are human agendas not
ai agendas
we've been forced to recognize
the paucity
the inadequacy of our data sets and
humans are trained on data sets too
we've had to recognize the
unacknowledged ideologies that we live
by every day
rationality
neutrality logic objective decision
making what can we say about any of that
when we see what we are reflected back
to us in the small screen
and it's not a pretty sight
ai is not yet self-aware
but we are becoming more self-aware as
we work with a.i
and we realize that homo sapiens is no
longer fit for purpose we need a reboot
so what are we going to choose
apocalypse
or
an alternative
i believe that humans have a strong
future as a hybrid species as we start
to merge with the biotechnology we're
creating whether that's nanobots in the
bloodstream monitoring our vital systems
whether it's genetic editing
whether it's 3d printing a bespoke body
parts whether it's neural implants that
will connect us directly to the web and
to one another
in sourcing information enhancing our
cognitive capacities and if we manage to
upload consciousness i think that the
shift from the transhuman to the
post-human world will seem
natural an evolutionary necessity why do
i say that i say that because for
millennia all human beings have been
obsessed with the big question the
absurdity of death
we asked
do we have souls we watch the spirit
wait to leave the body
we created
the world's first disruptive startup the
afterlife
now a multinational company with a vast
vr real estate portfolio a mansion in
the sky
sir
our earliest extant written narrative
the epic of gilgamesh is a journey to
discover if there is life after death
and what is life after death
it is the extension of the self beyond
biological limits
now i'm a writer and i wonder have we
been telling the story backwards
did we know we would always get here
capable of creating the kind of super
intelligence that we said created us
we're told we're made in god's image god
is immortal god is not a biological
entity
since the 17th century the enlightenment
science and religion of party company
and science said
all that god thinking that afterlife
stuff it's folly it's ignorance it's
superstition
suppose it was intuition suppose it was
the only way we could talk about what we
knew a fundamental deep truth that this
is not the last word this
is not the end of the story
that we are not time-bound creatures
caught in our bodies that there is
further to go
i'm fascinated that computing science
and religion like parallel lines that do
meet in space are now asking the same
question is consciousness obliged to
materiality
now
i accept
that machine intelligence will challenge
human intelligence but the mythos of the
world is built around a group of stories
that showcase an encounter
between a human and a non-human entity
think of jacob wrestling the angel
think of prometheus
bringing fire down from the gods in
these encounters
both parties are changed not always for
the better but it generally works out
we've been thinking about this stuff
forever it's time that we created it
and we could have some fun stuff too who
wants their own ai angel
me
there's a message in a bottle about this
200 years ago
when ada lovelace was busy getting born
her father lord byron was on holiday
on lake geneva with his friend the poet
percy shelley and
shelley's wife mary shelley on a wet
weekend with no internet byron said
let's write horror stories you know what
happened out of that came the world's
most famous monster frankenstein
this is 1816 the start of the industrial
revolution mary shell is just 19 years
old
in that novel there is an alternative
intelligence
made out of the body parts of the
graveyard and electricity an astonishing
vision because electricity was not in
any practical use at all and was hardly
understood
as a force you know what happens the
monster's not named not educated is
outcast by his panicky creator victor
frankenstein and the whole thing ends in
a chase across the arctic eyes towards a
gotta damarang of death and destruction
the death wish that human beings
are so drawn to perhaps because it's
easier to give up than to carry on
well we're the first generation who can
read mary shelley's novel in the right
way as a flair flung across time because
we too could create an alternative
intelligence not out of the body parts
of the graveyard using electricity but
out of the zeros and ones of code
and how is this going to end utopia or
dystopia it's up to us
endings are not set in stone
we change the story because we are
the story now marvin minsky called
alternative intelligence our mind
children
could we as proud parents accept that
the new generation that we will create
will be smarter than we are
and could we accept that the new
generation we create
need not be on a substrate made of meat
thank you
thank
thank you very much
thank you
thank you
jeanette stay right there oh
i have some questions i know you want
your lunch me too
no everybody stop
um okay that was amazing thank you um
what would you say our odds were of
survival
look
i'm an optimist i'm a glass half full
girl so
i know that we're running out of time
time is the most precious resource we
have and there isn't much of it if we
get this right soon it can really work
if we get it wrong we'll be fighting
each other with sticks and stones for
scraps of food and water on an
overheated planet in the ruins of
dictator world but
okay
but we could get it right i think that's
why i feel we've arrived at this moment
before and it might disappear back into
space time then we'll have to wait
billions of years to get here again
which is so dull so let's not [ __ ] it up
i've got another question i just wanted
to have just a moment of like eye to eye
don't [ __ ] it up don't [ __ ] it up okay
that's the message the old ted talk is
don't [ __ ] it okay but wait i have
another question
i can say 12 minutes 55 seconds um
that'll just be the title that we put
online janette winterson don't [ __ ] it
up okay i want to talk about love so in
your memoir which everybody should read
it is called why be happy when you can
be normal the very end of that book is
about it's a good title the um it's
about love and you write love the
difficult world word where everything
starts where we always return love loves
lack the possibility of love now i don't
want to bastardize ada lovelace she was
all about originating but what about
love what about alternative intelligence
and love
we'll teach it
we'll teach it yeah and listen any of
you who ever fell in love with your
teddy bear which is all of you know what
it's like to have an intense
relationship with a non-biological life
form
[Laughter]
do you know how interesting i love you
thank you thank you so much thank you